hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in his piece technologies of the self
michelle foucault spends a significant
portion discussing different
periods different traditions different
thinkers
and how they reconfigured or rethought
out the
care of the self and he talks about
these transformations that are taking
place in hellenistic and then
roman culture and and one of the things
that he says
that uh you can sort of generalize is
that in hellenistic and imperial periods
the socratic notion of the care of the
self became a common
universal philosophical theme so it
becomes
part of the general culture it becomes
part of specific
traditions specific approaches within
that culture ways of becoming
cultured ways of becoming a better
self becoming who one is supposed to be
and he talks about
how widespread this is now he mentions
the epicureans who are a non-socratic
school
but they are you know reacting to it and
they're the same theme is found there
he says care of the self was accepted by
epicurus and his followers by the cynics
and by such stoics as seneca rufus
and galen galen of course is not a stoic
but that that's perfectly fine
the pythagoreans gave attention to the
notion of an ordered life in common
this care the theme of the care of
itself is not abstract advice but a
widespread activity a network of
obligations and services
to the the soul and so and he's talking
about a number of different
um movements and you know we've got the
epicureans we've got the cynics
who are a socratic school descending
through
antisthenes or some scholars think
through diogenes it doesn't really
matter
because by the time that you know we're
deep in the hellenistic era there's many
uh cynics wandering around the stoics
definitely
uh who by the way are drawing on the
cynics
later platonists right he's going to
bring up plutarch
he's going to bring up neoplatonus they
are also concerned with this
we could say eclectics galen would fit
in there so would cicero
and interestingly he points out that
lucian satirizes this
and one way that you can tell that
something has really
caught on outside of like you know
strictly philosophical
circles is the fact that people are
making fun of it
right it's it's important enough to make
fun of
he also says it was
extremely widespread activity it brought
about competition between the
rhetoricians and those who turn towards
themselves
particularly over the question of the
role of the master and then he says
there were charlatans of course but
certain individuals
took it seriously and you know it's
interesting if you think about it
there's charlatans right
you can really only have charlatans if
there's also
the possibility perhaps the actuality
of the genuine article right so for for
every diogenes maybe there are three or
four
pseudo-diogenes who were just you know
looking for attention or something like
that but that doesn't take away from the
fact that there was a diogenes and these
are
possibilities for human beings to figure
out
how to understand themselves how to
transform themselves how to apply
the technologies of the self and so
foucault tells us
with the new care of the self comes the
possibility of
new experience of the self and you can
look at hellenistic
and you know roman literature as
you know prime examples of what's going
on with this how are people
now understanding the self themselves
and the general self what it is to be a
human being a fully developed human
being
in different ways now he talks about
some
important transformations as a historian
foucault is particularly
attuned to continuities and
discontinuities
so some of the transformations in the
the care of the self he
outlines a little bit later he says
to be concerned with the self and the
hellenistic and roman
periods is not exclusively a preparation
for
political life care of the self has
become a universal principle
one must leave politics to take better
care of the self
and yes and no i mean
the epicureans definitely thought you
should leave politics to take better
care of the self
cynics would get in the face of
political leaders they're doing politics
in a certain kind of way they're
conceiving of themselves heralds and
zeus
the stoics stress the need to be
involved
in politics and social life in a certain
way
to do one's you know offices or duties
so we could say that that maybe foucault
is overplaying his hand a little bit
here
but definitely there is a a new way of
of understanding
uh the relation to politics whether it
be on a you know sort of
large scale or on the local level
so the other another key transformation
is
it's and again maybe foucault is being a
little bit
too schematic here is that it's no
longer just for the young
as maybe it was for for
um plato right now it's a way
of living throughout one's life
although you know socrates himself
represents a certain way of doing that
and
in some of the dialogues he's discussing
things with other people who are middle
aged
or even older and are seem to be trying
to live
a particularly good kind of life but he
does talk a lot with
the youth so we can say definitely that
there is
like he says it's not obligatory just
for young people concerned with their
education it's a way of living for
everybody throughout their lives
is that latent there in the platonic
thing i would say yes
um he also says that self-knowledge is
playing a role the gnothy say out to
of the delphic maxim but it involves
other relations as well he doesn't
really spell
out what what he means by that but you
could say it's not
just oriented towards care of the self
knowing oneself is starting to take on
an importance
uh in its own right and he brings up you
know some some interesting things about
the body and one's day-to-day life he
says you can compare cicero to later
seneca or marcus aurelius
we see for example senecas and marcus's
meticulous concern with the details of
daily life
with the movement of the spirit with
self-analysis that we're not we're not
seeing in cicero
for example another thing that i think
is really important
is um the kind of models or paradigms
that we see getting used so
as opposed to a pedagogical model that
we see with plato
and it's not exclusively a pedagogical
model it's not as if
plato doesn't also talk about medicine
and
things like that but there is there is a
particularly pedagogical model
a medical model the therapy of the self
displaces and then eventually comes to
replace the pedagogical
model in many respects like he says the
care of the self isn't another kind of
pedagogy
it has become permanent medical care
one must become the doctor of one's self
a doctor who's sick
and who gets medical advice from other
sick doctors ultimately trying to become
cured and this leads to the next thing
preparing for a certain
complete achievement of life he says
this is something that you know the
objective is no longer to get prepared
for adult life
or for another life but to get prepared
for a certain complete achievement of
life
this achievement is complete at the
moment just prior to death
and he says there's a there's an
inversion here of the typical greek
views on youth and and i think there's
something to this
i would say that's already there
discussed in
in aristotle's nick mccain ethics book
one
about you know do we have to wait until
somebody's dead before we call them
happy so it's it's not
quite so simple as that and you can say
definitely from the
epicurean perspective you're not just
waiting for death you're enjoying your
life on the way
because death is the end for epicureans
even for stoics quite frankly i mean
there's this vague notion of maybe being
able to live on
you know in some sort of stellar life
but that's not for most people
[Music]
so each of these is a transformation
that's taking place
is it as cut and dried as foucault is
making it out perhaps
perhaps not he does talk about new
practices that are that are quite
important as well and
he says that we see the disappearance of
dialogue
the increasing importance of a new
pedagogical relationship
where the master or teacher speaks does
not ask questions the disciple does not
answer
but must listen and keep silent
a cultivation of silence becomes more
and more important
in pythagorean cultivation now that's
going way back
prior to even you know socrates and
plato
but disciples kept silent for five years
as a pedagogical rule
they developed the art of listening as
the positive condition for acquiring
truth
this tradition is picked up during the
imperial period
and we see the beginning of the
cultivation of silence and the art of
listening
rather than cultivation of dialogue as
in plato
and so he says to learn the art of
listening we need to read plutarch's
treaties on the art of listening to
lectures
which can also mean you know so perry to
akuen
listening also obeying right at the
beginning of this treatise plutarch says
following schooling we must learn to
listen to logos
there's reason or speech throughout our
entire life
it's crucial so that you can tell what's
true and what is dissimulation what is
rhetorical truth what is falsehood
listening is linked to the fact that the
dis disciple is not under the control of
the masters
but must listen to logos one keeps
silent at the lecture one thinks about
it
afterwards so then he gives some other
examples you know filo
alexandria talking about uh banquets
where people are
reading and the reading is being
listened to and i think there's
something to that you know we know for
example in the way that
schooling was going on that there would
be like for example
among the stoics reading some crucifix
then the teacher comments on it we do
know however though
that there also was back and forth going
on at other points
as well but you could say there's a
a practice of shut up listen
think take it in and then only
afterwards come back right
examination of conscience another big
thing and this again
goes back quite a ways but it attains a
real significance
in the the you know roman period
seneca for example suggesting to us that
we should certainly you know at the
end of the day think what did i do well
with what did i not do well with
also forgive oneself for one's one's
faults
um examination of how one did
throughout the day so as to establish
not just a habit but also
a continual attentiveness to
to oneself a review you could say and
then there's a
host of different stoic practices
that he describes as technologies
of the self we'll just give you know
some examples of the
this you know letters to friends
disclosure self examination of self
and consciousness right and then escasis
but we'll talk about that
elsewhere as a separate set
of technologies of the self the point is
that
with between these different schools
and within hellenistic and
roman culture there is an ongoing
reconsideration and further development
of
technologies of the self going beyond
what plato socrates even aristotle
perhaps in the lyceum were offering
and this you know this is bringing new
things to the table you might say in
terms of
what we in the present can draw upon and
say well maybe there's something there
that we could use in our own
technologies of the self for
our own care of the self
you